it's just past 10 GMT and we start in
key where Ukrainian officials say four
people have been killed in Russian drone
strikes on the region military sources
say a civilian object was damaged in the
attack and rescue workers are still on
the scene well for more on this let's
bring in our correspondent Stephanie
Decker she's live for us in Kiev it's
the first attack on a residential
building in the key of region in Mount
Stephanie what more do we know about it
yes the first since December actually
videos just emerged at night which shows
you can hear the sound of a drone just
before you see the explosion light up
the night sky the fourth and fifth
stories of two residential buildings
they're being described as dormitories
by the head of the Regional Police there
for killed as you mentioned two were
injured and from what we understand a
rescue operation goes on 16 drones were
shot out of the sky intercepted by
Ukrainian air defenses overnight out of
21 we understand the Ukrainian President
also addressed the incident calling the
murderous drones and saying as they
refer to peace in Moscow orders are
given to launch these kinds of good
drones of course referring there to
China's peace plan that was uh at some
point discussed on the table between
those two leaders again you know Kiev is
of course the capital it
does still see attacks much more
sporadic of course long-range missiles
particularly targeting its civilian
infrastructure like power plants
electricity plants and then you still
have these kinds of incidents which is a
reminder that it does remain an act of
War Zone the air sirens do go off pretty
much on a daily basis people have long
ignored those air sirens in the key of
local police who was quoted as part of
this operation of rescue said that the
fourth person killed was a 40 year old
driver that they removed from the
building saying he did not listen to the
air raid sirens but you know the reality
is that a year on to this war when you
have those Sirens going on on a daily
basis people simply have to go on with
their daily lives
Stephanie thank you very much for that
that is Stephanie Decker with the latest
live in Kiev
and in Crimea Russian officials say the
Navy has repelled a drone attack on the
sevasta ball Port this comes two days
after an explosion on the peninsula
destroyed Russian missiles that's
according to Ukraine's defense Ministry
they were intended for use by moscow's
Black Sea Fleet the Russian
administrator of zankoy has said the
city had come under attack from drones
let's bring in journalist Julia
chapovalovan now from Moscow and the
kremlin-backed mayor of sevastaval uh
Sebastopol is saying that the Russian
Navy repelled this drone attack
um on the port in Russian Annex Crimea
the port of sevastopol that is what are
you hearing about this in Moscow New
Year
um that's correct here in Moscow we are
receiving reports that the Black Sea
Fleet are repelled the attack by
Ukrainian drones which destroyed three
objects according to the governor of
sevastopol mihail rasbajev he published
the information in his Telegraph Channel
he said that the drones tried to get to
the bait into the bay the sailors the
Russian Sailors fired small arms at them
and there were no casualties some
windows into buildings residential
buildings would blown out due to
explosions caused by destroyed drones so
the attack happened at around eight in
the morning local time so basically the
all-out war is expanding and as you said
not so long ago a massive strike by
several Ukrainian uavs was carried out
in John koi on the Crimean Peninsula
late Monday evening on March the 20th at
least six uavs of the Chinese mughin 5
type equipped with closed captioning not
available
all right Yulia thank you for that that
is Julia were live in Moscow thank you
after more than a year of War here's
where things stand on the ground Russia
controls much of the territory east of
the donipro river a Ukrainian counter
offensive in the Autumn reclaimed
swathes of land in the North and South
including the city of Kirsten now the
fighting is concentrated on the city of
Bak moth where the two sides have been
locked in an extended stalemate we're
going to bring in Achilles despress he's
the Ukraine spokesperson for the
international Committee of the Red Cross
and he's joining us live from Keith
thank you very much for your time on Al
Jazeera if we look at the fighting
that's been taking place around the city
of Bachman what is the situation for
people remaining in and around backward
now
look I was myself in localities around
bakmut on Friday and our teams went
there again on Saturday in the areas
very close to the city and in other
areas near the front line
the scale of Destruction is shocking it
very few buildings haven't been
destroyed or damaged we are seeing when
we are driving there with our convoys of
humanitarian Aid we are seeing schools
homes hospitals that have been destroyed
and it's incredible to imagine that
civilians are still living in these
areas but they are that's why it's so
important that we are bringing them
humanitarian Aid because people living
in these areas are lacking the
essentials they're lacking water they're
lacking food they're lacking hygiene
items they're lacking repair material to
repair broken windows or broken doors so
they're living in very very dire
conditions and that's what we at the
international Committee of the Red Cross
are trying to help them with in these
very difficult circumstances and what
about evacuating people from bakmud I
know that most of the population of
bakmut
are you able to get everyone out is
everyone living in buckmore willing to
leave especially given that many of the
people who are there have been displaced
so many times already
as you said most civilians living in the
city of bakmut have already evacuated
however they have sometimes evacuated to
cities that are very close to bakmut or
very close to the active Frontline I
spoke myself to a city a member of the
city council of bakmut and she told me
that in the city of constantinica which
is right after bachni more than 200
families from bakmut are living and
basically when they left because the
hostilities were just too intense or
because the front line was coming too
close to them they had nothing with them
but what they could carry that they need
really everything from clothes to
blankets to hygiene items so even people
who have already evacuated from the most
active areas of fighting they still
remain very close to the front line and
they still have really basic
humanitarian needs and we should also
not forget that in areas close to the
front lines and in the cities close to
Batman there are also some people who
simply cannot evacuate because they're
elderly because they are low Mobility or
also people who simply refuse to leave
their homes so that's why it's
incredibly important that humanitarian
actors such as the international
Committee of the Red Cross are able to
bring in this assistance into these very
dangerous areas that sadly civilians are
still living in and as you mentioned
there are so many elderly there are
people with mobility issues but for
those who can leave but choose not to I
mean they're not going to be convinced
by the fact that they can't actually go
very far they're just going to be around
back mode and they are still going to be
dependent on this humanitarian
assistance so is there anything that you
can actually do to convince the people
who can leave to leave
look for us our objective is not
necessarily to convince people to leave
but it's also to serve the needs of the
people wherever they are we know that's
civilians remain next to the front line
in these areas that are very dangerous
and when I spoke to people there I spoke
to a young man a 19 year old man named
Daniel who was telling me that he could
leave but he just doesn't want to
because he has a grandfather in the area
he has lots of elderly people in this in
this Village that he is living in and he
just doesn't want to leave them and this
is a situation that we can all
understand as a very difficult situation
nevertheless we need to help these
people where they are and we need to
provide them with basic things just late
last week I was on a convoy that managed
to bring 17 tons of food to areas near
the front line and 6 000 liters of
drinking water to these communities so
that's what they need to
simply survive as one resident of these
cities the man named Nikolai told me
very bluntly people here are not really
living they're merely surviving and
that's what we have to help them do in
these very difficult conditions Mr
desperate as we thank you very much for
bringing us the picture
um from the humanitarian situation after
months of fighting around it that is a
kitty Des Peres of the international
Committee of the Red Cross joining us
live from Keith thank you so much for
your time
thanks for having me
and Chinese president Xi Jinping